when you think of Kang foo or wushu
names like Bruce Lee and Jackie Chan
spring to mind those names are inspiring
more than 12,000 people who have taken
up the sport in Senegal I really like
Chinese movies sometimes I see the towel
that we are practicing here in a film
China's influence was clear to see as 11
countries took part in the African wushu
Championships in Senegal a qualifying
event for the world champs in Shanghai
next month
the Chinese visit Congo and we always do
activities together
the Chinese help us enormous Lee even
the metal that we gave to our athlete at
the national championships were taking
care of by China spoke wushu is broken
into two categories it features the
disciplines of taolu which showcases a
routine of choreographed techniques
[Applause]
and also sander which is a combat sport
that mixes punching kicking and
wrestling both men and women compete
young and old of course it's difficult
and it's a challenge for girls to take
part in wushu it's the same as for boys
it's normal but in the ring it's not
violent fighting basically it teaches us
to control our anger and what I learned
here is that one shouldn't go looking
for trouble it's only for self-defense
we are taught solidarity we are like a
big family and bit by bit we are
learning the values of kung-fu and I
love it and it's that attitude that's
helping martial arts encourage more
women into sport in West Africa where
participation levels are historically
low poor vanderwerff al Jazeera